حسب معلومات نشرتها صحيفه نيويورك تايمز
فان زعيم كوريا الشماليه كيم جون اون الذي
نادرا ما يسافر خارج بلاده سيلتقي هذا
الشهر الرئيس الروسي فلاديمير بوتين على
الارجح في فلاديفوكا الواقعه على الساحل
الروسي قرب كوريا الشماليه في اطار
مفاوضات الاسلحه الجاريه بين البلدين بهدف
امداد موسكو باسلحه
مدفعيه وصواريخ مضاده للدبابات وكميات من
الذخائر والامدادات اللازمه لحرب روسيا في
اوكرانيا وكانت واشنطن قد عبرت الاسبوع
الماضي عن قلقها البالغ بشان تقدم السريع
في المفاوضات
وموسكو نواصل مراقبه الوضع عن كثب ونحض
جمهوريه كوريا الشماليه على وقت مفاوضات
الاسلحه مع روسيا والالتزام بتعهدات
العلنيه التي قطعتها
بعدم تزويد روسيا او بيعها اسلحه في الطرف
المقابل تسع كوريا الشماليه للحصول على
مساعدات غذائيه بالاضافه الى تقنيات
متقدمه للقمر الصناعيه والغواصات حسب
البيت الابيض فان هذه المفاوضات بدات
النهايه يوليو تموز الماضي بزياره وزير
الدفاع الروسي سيرجي شويغو الى كوريا
الشماليه غير ان الولايات المتحده
وبريطانيا وكوريا الجنوبيه واليابان اعلنت
الاسبوع الماضي في بيان مشترك في الامم
المتحده ان اي اتفاق لزياده التعاون
الثنائي بين روسيا وكوريا الشماليه سيعد
انتهاكا لقرارات مجلس الامن الدولي التي
تحضر عقد صفقات اسلحه مع بيونج يونج وهي
قرارات ايدتها موسكو نفسها